de très nombreux médicaments sont en
rupture de stock y compris des
médicaments très importants et la
situation ne fait que de s'empirer alors
pourquoi cette pénurie combien de temps
ça va durer quels sont les solutions
Ludovic taureau docteur qu'on adore et
qui est venu me voir une fois qui était
incroyable viendra nous en parler et il
viendra nous parler de cette situation
de cette situation très peu occupante et
il sera accompagné de Franck qui a chopé
et échappé au pire après une grippe
aucune pharmacie n'avait son médicament
petit récap et on en parle juste après
on a des extraits d'hier soir sur France
2 regarde
hier soir France 2 diffuser un nouveau
numéro d'envoyer spécial sur un sujet
choc qui préoccupe les Français notre
enquête sur ces pénuries de médicaments
qui se multiplient à cause des
nombreuses délocalisations de production
de médicaments dans des pays comme la
Chine ou encore l'Inde les pharmacies
rencontrent aujourd'hui de grosses
difficultés pour s'approvisionner ça
faisait déjà arrivé
d'approvisionnement qui pourrait avoir
des conséquences dramatiques puisque des
millions de Français pourraient ainsi ne
plus réussir à se procurer des
médicaments essentiels de quoi effrayer
les parents danger c'est le ressenti
qu'on a révélation choc autour de la
pénurie de médicaments partout en France
le pire est-il à venir
merci à Ludovico médecin d'être avec
nous ce soir merci Ludovic c'est la
deuxième fois que vous venez vous avez
tous les documents
et Franck victime d'une rupture de
médicaments parlant rupture de
médicaments hier il y avait envoyé
Spécial sur France 2 l'émission est allé
à la rencontre d'une mère de famille qui
galère depuis plusieurs semaines pour
trouver des médicaments qui ont été
prescrits à sa fille regardez une
situation très angoissante lorsqu'on a
un enfant malade regardez elle a quoi
exactement là alors elle a une angine et
une conjonctivite et qu'est-ce qui vous
prescrit
alors il me prescrit du doliprane de
l'amoxicilline ça veut dire que ça va
être compliqué à trouver c'est à dire
c'est à dire que le doliprane elle a
déjà été malade et un petit moment et ça
a été compliqué on a fait plusieurs
pharmacies pour trouver du doliprane et
l'amoxicilline pour les enfants on a eu
du mal aussi on a été obligé de prendre
de l'amoxicilline adulte donc ça veut
dire que c'est la pénurie quoi et vous
imaginiez vivre ça là en France en 2023
non on se demande comment ça va aller
dans le futur comment ça va se passer
s'il va falloir trouver d'autres
médicaments donc fleur d'oranger pour la
fièvre des choses comme ça alors
Ludovico qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les
médicaments là ça fait 33 ans que je
suis médecin généraliste j'ai jamais vu
ça vous savez le droit à la santé est un
droit absolu par l'OMS en France il n'y
a plus on a commencé à enlever les
médecins et aujourd'hui il y a plus de
médicaments je sais pas si vous vous en
rendez compte mais ça les réalités moi
j'ai appelé mon pharmacien vous savez ce
qui fait quand il arrive le matin
d'abord il est angoissé il met quelqu'un
sur un ordinateur parce qu'il commande
les médicaments sur des plateformes il y
a tous les noms des médicaments
c'est en rouge dès que ça passe en vert
il s'appuie pour faire une commande de
100 boîtes ils ont soif que 10 voilà où
on en est aujourd'hui moi j'ai formé
prescrit une ordonnance d'antibiotiques
il m'appelle je l'ai pas celui-là j'y
mets ce que tu as celui-là j'ai pas mais
celui-là il y en a plus il a devant lui
des moments qui pleurent parce que
l'enfant le nourrisson il lui faut de
doliprane en pipette sauf qu'il est
réservé au service hospitalier parce
qu'il y en a pas assez donc il faut 10
20 pharmacies aujourd'hui les pharmacies
reçoivent des coups de fil est-ce que
vous avez eu doliprane est-ce que vous
avez du clamoxil et 6e puissance
mondiale ce qui va arriver dans les cinq
ans qui vont venir va être
catastrophique si on change pas très
rapidement le logiciel ça fait 30 ans
qu'ils ont pas le logiciel le seul
logiciel c'est l'argent sauf que la
santé c'est pas l'argent c'est vous et
nous et je vous assure que vous aurez
beaucoup de problèmes et même si on
bouge maintenant alors qu'on aurait ils
ont fait tout pour arriver là
aujourd'hui alors dites-nous pourquoi on
en arrive là alors je vous le dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe le gouvernement
est très intelligent alors qu'on a pris
10 millions d'habitants depuis 30 ans et
je prends 6 ans en espérance de vie il
faut serrer la vis donc d'abord on fait
plus de soignants comme c'est nous qui
presqueions il y a plus de dépenses très
intelligent deuxième chose les
médicaments coûtent trop cher donc en
France vous en faites plus on va les
faire autre part et on les fait en Chine
et en Inde 80% des médicaments sont fait
en Chine en un mais c'est pas des petits
médicaments c'est des médicaments de
cancero de cardio de diabète et sachez
qu'aujourd'hui 40% des Français 40%
prennent un médicament tous les jours si
ces pays deviennent un peu fous la Chine
c'est pas une démocratie ils nous disent
on livre plus mais les enfants on va
mourir c'est à dire qu'on parle beaucoup
de militaires mais là il y a une guerre
une guerre médicamenteuse une guerre de
santé et quoi personne bouge on nous a
annoncé super dans trois ans on aura une
usine de doliprane c'est la blague
est-ce que c'est pas la blague c'est et
ces gens qu'on voit là mais c'est une
catastrophe c'est tous les jours alors
justement parliez des pharmaciens
regardez chez un extrait les stocks sont
tellement faibles que les pharmaciens
eux-mêmes partent à la recherche de
poudre de gélules et de stock de
médicaments
oui alors là je viens directement au
dépôt pour venir chercher le colis parce
qu'on peut pas attendre c'est
l'amoxicilline pour tout le sud en fait
c'est tous les préparateurs du Sud qui
attendent ce colis pour qu'on puisse
recommencer la production cet après-midi
donc ça peut pas attendre l'amoxicilline
c'est le médicament que tout le monde
s'arrache depuis mi-novembre
l'antibiotique le plus prescrit aux
enfants si elle ne parvient pas à
récupérer la marchandise des milliers de
malades se retrouveront sans traitement
le voici ce précieux colis avec à
l'intérieur de quoi éviter une pénurie
dramatique d'antibiotiques dans ce sac
en vrac 3500 euros de poudre de
molécules actives de quoi soigner 8000
personnes c'est incroyable on va faire
des médicaments dans l'autre cave
maintenant sérieuse alors sixième
puissance mondiale mais vous savez ça
s'accroît c'est une on pourrait se dire
qu'ils ont réfléchi depuis quelques
années parce qu'il y a eu deux rapports
en 2017 à la fois de la fac à l'Académie
de pharmacie et du Sénat qui dit faut
faire quelque chose rien à bouger on a
augmenté les importations de médicaments
alors vous avez nous expliquer tout ça
parce que vous allez voir aussi la
réponse des labos et vous allez voir
comment on en est arrivé là aussi dans
un instant juste Franck vous vous êtes
vous avez été victime d'une rupture de
médicaments qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je
suis rentré je suis rentré d'urgence à
l'hôpital pour un problème de calcul de
8 mm qui était bloqué sorti d'un je me
fais donc une opération un peu lourde
mais en tout cas qui est courte dans la
durée je sors de l'hôpital on me
prescrit donc des médicaments pour pas
qu'il y ait éventuellement d'infection
là-dessus je chope une grippe et on
prescrit donc l'amoxicilline dont on
parle dans le reportage entre autres
sans parler de d'autres médicaments et
lorsque j'arrive dans la première
pharmacie rupture totale deuxième
pharmacie rupture totale on fait 7 comme
ça dessus rupture totale donc je sors en
grande faiblesse d'une opération je suis
pas en grande forme je commence à faire
de la fièvre et tous les médicaments qui
pourraient éventuellement calmer la
fièvre et me permettre d'être mieux et
bien pas une pharmacie qui peut me
produire ça a duré 15 jours donc pendant
15 jours je suis chez moi mon médecin
m'a prolongé mon arrêt maladie de
l'opération du fait et ça a duré donc je
suis resté en arrêt maladie pendant un
mois jusqu'à au bout d'un moment on a
une gentille pharmacienne qui a pris qui
a eu un peu de peine et qui m'a appelé
en disant écoutez j'ai j'en ai rentré
trois boîtes je vous en ai gardé une si
vous pouvez nous envoyer quelqu'un
éventuellement je vous je me suis
éventuellement vous en passer une ben je
suis dit le problème c'est que
[Musique]
c'est ce qui me fait peur c'est que si
ça ça passe pas vous me donnez une boîte
je crois que dans la boîte il y a 8
cachets j'avais prescription de
plusieurs cachets la durée était un peu
plus longue et d'écouter soyez déjà
content mais ça va durer combien de
temps et elle m'a dit on n'en sait rien
on n'en sait rien alors et là j'appelle
là mon beau-frère qui habite le sud-est
de la France il dit si tu veux je vais
en Italie je vais t'en chercher je sais
pas comment je vois pas bien en Italie
ils ont pas de rupture de médicaments en
Italie et je te l'envoie par la poste
alors justement on va vous montrer ça
parce qu'on a tous envie de savoir que
répondre les laboratoires à cette
pénurie regardez et après quelques
kilomètres de la frontière les
pharmacies ouvrent leurs portes aux
clients français à la recherche de
paracétamol ou d'antibiotiques
c'est pas générique mais c'est la même
molécule antibiotiques antibiotiques
pour finir mon traitement parce que il y
a en France on en trouve plus
de la frontière on décompte pour les
personnes qui habitent dans le centre de
la France comment ils font avant les
fêtes cette formation avait fait des
stocks mais les clients français l'ont
dévalisé
beaucoup oui à partir de Noël selon les
pharmaciens français si l'Italie ne
subit pas pour le moment de pénurie
c'est parce que les industriels
privilégient l'exportation dans des pays
où le médicament est vendu plus cher
qu'en France
regardez ce qui avait répondu les
laboratoires avant quand on leur a
demandé pourquoi il y a plus de
médicaments là on voit qu'il s'est vendu
plus cher qu'en France mais regardez
quelle est la responsabilité des
laboratoires dans cette pénurie produit
style assez visiblement non en Amérique
latine en Afrique et en Asie
la hausse du niveau de vie de la
population fait augmenter la
consommation en médicament l'industrie
pharmaceutique a aussi fait un choix qui
aggrave la pénurie la délocalisation
pour baisser leur coûts ils ont déplacé
une partie de leur production la
molécule de base du médicament est
fabriquée dans des usines installée la
plupart du temps à des milliers de
kilomètres de la France surtout en Chine
et en Inde
donc Ludovic Toro quand on voit ça donc
les raisons pour lesquelles on n'a pas
de médicaments est-ce que vous pouvez
nous les résumer pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent et
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des
entreprises les entreprises font des
bénéfices où ils en font pas ils sont
rendus compte que la politique française
c'était absolument de descendre le coût
de la santé donc on peut pas les faire
en France donc comme tous ils vont les
faire très très loin c'est pas juste à
côté c'est jusqu'en Inde d'accord et il
y a 80%, ça serait 20%, 25 mais on est à
quand même à une dépendance de 80%
pendant donc je vous le dis très
clairement il y a un danger sanitaire
pour notre pays on est tenu par les
autres pour se faire soigner on parle
tout le temps d'autonomie on a pu
l'autonomie sur la santé par cette
décision initiale de la fin des
soignants et par cette deuxième décision
qui fait qu'on ne produit plus en France
et voilà il y a des choses qu'on peut
décentraliser on peut pas décentraliser
la santé parce que c'est nous qui allons
payer alors aujourd'hui
ils disent quoi les pharmaciens c'est
quoi les stocks qu'ils ont ils ont ils
ont pas ils savent même pas vous savez
ils ont jamais vécu ça moi j'ai eu un
pharmacien qui a 35 ans voilà qui est
installé il a jamais ça fait des années
et des années qu'on sait qu'il y a des
médicaments en rupture régulièrement de
de son on est passé pratiquement à 3000
en 2022 on le savait mais là c'est pire
que ça c'est là il y en a plus une
rupture c'est qu'il y en a plus quand
vous avez un nourrisson à qui on doit
faire descendre la fièvre et qu'on fait
l'hospitalise pas on peut plus le faire
descendre la fièvre là on en est
aujourd'hui et on va dire qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire pour changer ça 80%
contre 20 et ben il va falloir vraiment
une volonté politique pour dire qu'on va
payer la santé on doit mettre de
l'argent sur la santé il y a 50 ans vous
tombiez sur la tête on faisait une radio
aujourd'hui on fait un IRM il y a 50 ans
vous avez un infarctus peut-être que
vous embrouillez aujourd'hui on met des
stèles c'est pas le même prix c'est pas
le même prix il faut le comprendre la
santé a appris et les Français
comprendront qu'on met de l'argent là et
c'est là le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
pour la santé et peut-être moins pour le
reste alors parce que là vous nous
inquiétez vous vous dites NON je
m'inquiète tous c'est fini alors moi
j'ai appelé une pharmacie qui me dit je
vais fermer il y a des queues revenus
clamoxy il renvoie à l'autre pharmacie
qui fait l'autre pharmacie je veux dire
ça un pour arriver à la fin comme enfin
vous expliquer et donc là on a plus de
boulangerie plus de resto plus de
pharmacies vous avez tout résumé c'est à
dire que les choses indispensables dans
notre pays ben on les aura plus non mais
comment on fait mais comment on fait il
faut que quand il y a des gouvernements
depuis 30 ans ils arrêtent de réfléchir
avec deux trois technocrates qui
prennent des 1 €, des 2 € aujourd'hui on
dit qu'on va vivre jusqu'à 90 ans dans
30 ans mais il faut vivre bien si on
peut plus avoir de médicaments
excusez-moi ça va être compliqué si on
peut pas avoir le médicament ça va être
compliqué donc là aujourd'hui c'est une
urgence faut que les ministres de la
Santé se bougent un peu Véran et le
nouveau là qui se bouge un tout petit
peu c'est le porte-paro maintenant
c'est qu'il a pas bougé parce que le
rapport il a eu alors vous savez que bah
tiens je vais faire une émission avec
Olivier Veyron là je vais l'annoncer
très vite bonne nouvelle apparemment je
vous inviterai merci je suis là voilà
très bien
j'ai rêvé attends il est prêt à discuter
avec tout le monde
et il est prêt à faire une émission avec
moi on s'est rencontré c'est bien passé
on va faire une émission ensemble que je
vais annoncer très vite et je vous dis
alors vous avez rêvé que vous faisiez
une émission avec Olivier j'ai dit
plusieurs fois sur le taux parce que je
vais sur quelques plateaux je lui dis
parce que personne répond en fait il
répond jamais on va la voir en direct
moi je vais lui poser qu'est-ce que je
vous ai dit qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
depuis 5 ans pour qu'on récupère un tout
petit peu de doliprane des choses comme
ça pour sauver les Français monsieur le
docteur alors
aujourd'hui Ludovico parce qu'il y a
plein de Français qui nous regardent et
qui sont comme nous tous ici très
inquiet ce qu'on se dit voilà on comment
on fait si on a si on a plus de
médicaments est-ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui
des délais est-ce qu'on peut se dire
voilà dans deux semaines ça allait mieux
notre scène ou bien là où est-ce qu'on
est ce que c'est cuit on est on est
interrogé un pharmacien il est il arrive
il met son écran hop fournisseur rouge
hop j'appuie là mais ils appuie tous en
même temps parce que tous les
pharmaciens font ça tous les journées et
du coup au lieu de 40 boîtes on se
reçoit deux boîtes on nous file les
comptes boots des boîtes d'amoxicilline
6e puissance mondiale comment alors mais
mais comment faire mais Cyril non mais
comment on fait et on peut pas parce que
il y a autre chose et ceux qui
fabriquent les médicaments qui sont des
sociétés à but lucratif si vous avez un
pays qui va payer la boîte 2 euros et
vous la payez un euro ils vont aller où
les médicaments
on peut pas riche donc ils exportent là
où ils vont plus cher
et la problématique il faut un peu
serrer les vis mais surtout faut
anticiper il faut prévoir et surtout
faut un moment changer de logiciel et
quand on voit qu'il y a eu des alertes
depuis 10 à 20 à 30 ans il y a rien qui
change quoi et cette relocalisation des
sites de production mais oui
la seule qui a été annoncée c'est celle
en France sur le doliprane qui ouvrira
dans deux ans c'est ça maintenant ce
qu'il faut faire c'est une
reconnaissance européenne en fait faut
que l'Europe d'accord plutôt que de
passer des démocraties en Europe
d'accord dans les autres pays on est
quand même très dépendants s'il décide
parce qu'on a dit une bêtise de couper
le robinet
ceux qui sont hypertendus diabétique on
va avoir du mal mais même les
anti-cancéreux donc aujourd'hui il faut
avoir une politique européenne de santé
et relocalisée
Ludovic juste comment on fait
aujourd'hui concrètement
par jour sinon
vous avez pensé à 5000 € par jour mais
oui en fait
et ben ils ont une solution ils vont
appeler leur pharmacie qui va appeler
une autre pharmacie qui va appuyer une
autre formation qui va appeler une autre
pharmacie et vous risquez d'être en
rupture
mais ce que je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui que que cette politique
aujourd'hui aboutit au bout du bout
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est touchés
que sur les médicaments antibiotiques et
pour la fièvre on n'est pas encore trop
touché je dis bien sur tous ces
pathologies chroniques et soit le
diabète etc ça pour l'instant mais qui
nous dit que demain ces gens qui sont
totalement libres se disent pas je vais
vendre la celui-là qui me donne 4 € de
plus on ne peut pas l'empêcher c'est
pour ça qu'il faut relocaliser en Europe
et qu'on soit pas dépendant de pays qui
sont souvent pas des démocraties
j'ai oublié de vous dire une chose
importante c'est qu'à un moment un
pharmacien mais monsieur dans l'état où
vous êtes allé faire un saut à l'hôpital
eux ils vont vous donner de
l'antibiotique et je suis arrivé à
l'hôpital on m'a dit de voir j'ai
attendu 8h pour qu'on s'occupe de moi ça
c'est le premier problème et au bout de
8 heures on a l'émission va vous faire
une ordonnance je vais vous présenter je
suis pas bien compris
monsieur on nous aussi on est en pénurie
il y a un vrai problème aussi de notre
côté donc il y a des cas plus graves que
vous et je suis en partie avec une
ordonnance voilà mais dans les hôpitaux
il vous demande d'amener vos médicaments
parce que ils peuvent pas vous des gens
arrivent aujourd'hui ils ont pas les
médicaments donc vous envoyez mais en
fait il y a pas de réserve il y a rien
et il y a pas de vision c'est ça la
problématique
du docteur est très énervée moi mon
docteur c'est un docteur vous connaissez
qui est venu sur splato qui s'appelle le
docteur bobotte il est dans le même état
il est dans le même état c'est qui il
prend son téléphone il appelle les
pharmacies pour savoir qui
éventuellement pourrait répondre à des
questions avec le travail qu'ils ont
avec mais
vous avez tout résumé il y a déjà pas de
médecin et quand vous trouvez un médecin
il y a pas de médicaments non mais c'est
on fait quoi pourquoi avec l'argent mais
ça c'est prévisible c'était prévisible
il fallait anticiper ça fait 30 années
et non faut faire encore des coupes à la
sécurité sociale des coupes de quoi on a
pris 10 millions ici des six années donc
de plus de vie c'est pas des couples
c'est ouvrir et ça ils sont dans une
logique comptable que nous allons payer
c'est nous et notre santé qui va les
payer c'est les nourrissons aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de doliprane et
c'est nous qu'on aura des pathologies
chroniques on pourra plus en avoir parce
qu'aujourd'hui en effet c'est sur les
maladies infectieuses mais qui nous dit
que demain sera pas les autres
pathologies rien il y a rien de signé
personnes qui m'a dit mais Ludovic je
vais fermer je peux plus donner genre
arrive on essaie de négocier sur un
autre médicament qui a pas la même
efficacité qui a pas le même spectre on
va donner par défaut à notre médicament
qui était pas pour cette maladie non
mais attendez on parlait mais ça fait 30
ans que j'ai vu ça arrivait depuis 30
ans et le manque de médicaments il nous
appelait ou revenez tout ça et là on est
dans le dur là on est dans le trait dur
même on est dans le traduit alors
justement à la question la question là
on prévoit quand même un certain nombre
de morts parce que je sais qu'ils ont
manque de médicaments pour le cancer
pour les reins on l'a vu tout à l'heure
derrière vous c'est quoi la solution
c'est-à-dire vous avez des gens qui qui
vont mourir parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
avoir de vous pas tort pourquoi parce
que déjà sur la plus de médecins ça veut
dire votre pathologie quand elle sera
prise en charge ce sera beaucoup trop
tard vous aurez déjà avancé dans la
pathologie sur les médicaments c'est
pareil un nourrisson qui fait 42 fièvre
il peut convaincer si vous laissez deux
jours comme ça il y aura forcément des
des effets secondaires à ce manque de
médicaments pour combattre les maladies
que vous avez on peut pas prévoir
aujourd'hui sinon c'est une catastrophe
mais en effet
aura répondu à ça le docteur Bruno va
répondre à ça tous les deux pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas vous aider mais une
vraie politique de protection sanitaire
des citoyens vous pensez qu'il y a des
solutions ou bien non
mais ils ont des solutions là ou bien si
vous voyez le budget de la Sécu qui
n'augmente pas de solution ce qui se
rendent compte du problème immédiat
parce que
ils sont là haut non là faut qu'il
vienne avec nous moi je les invite
verront je vais faire voir la pharmacie
il va consulter avec moi ça lui
rappellera quelques petits souvenirs et
il va voir la réalité en tout cas il est
prêt à discuter avec tout le monde a
donné toutes les réponses je vous le dis
il a été et les solutions les solutions
parce que les réponses on les a toujours
demain
ah non je veux des solutions des actes
budget de la Sécu ça se voit en ce
moment allez qu'est-ce qu'on met en plus
sur la table pour enfin retrouver une
autonomie sanitaire
pour vraiment pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent qui ont besoin de
médicaments aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a
une solution à court terme pour que il y
ait des dernières ports très vite là et
les semaines qui arrivent alors que les
gens puissent sortir on va les rassurer
sur toutes les pathologies chroniques
aujourd'hui sur les pathologies aiguës
infectieuses il faut qu'il fasse
plusieurs pharmacies d'accord mais à un
moment ils vont trouver ah ouais mais
attendez normalement la fille elle a
disparu ou alors l'hôpital
demander un pharmacien ça met beaucoup
trop de temps c'est les pathologies
infectieuses sont les pathologies aigus
qui vont pas supporter 7 jours de
décalage d'accord donc moralité là non
on est dans une grande difficulté et
certains n'ont pas il faut souffrir
voilà pour moi mais oui mais Cyril on
peut souffrir quand on s'y attend pas
mais quand on s'y attend écoutez
excusez-moi il y a aucune excuse mais
c'était prévisible
c'est des rapports ça fait 20 ans que
les rapports tombent chaque année en
disant faut faire quelque chose et
arrêter cette dépendance qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait rien on a accru la dépendance
voilà le résultat et la décision si
c'est pas une incompétence
gouvernementale en termes de santé j'y
comprends rien quel que soit le
gouvernement du gouvernement success
je fais pas de politique
il fallait plus descendre il fallait
faire des économies sur la santé et bon
on y va vous économies on a plus rien
donc là plus rien
il galère ça va se passer parce que ça
va arrêter les pathologies infectieuses
dans quelques mois mais ça va être
terrible pour les familles comme des
talents qui cherchaient du doliprane ou
un antibiotique comme Monsieur voilà
c'est terrible proposer l'Internet
les gens ils m'ont dit mais pourquoi tu
vas pas sur Internet médicaments sur
Internet on le trouve j'ai trouvé
c'était de la folie quoi c'était une
folie douce de pouvoir aller acheter des
médicaments qu'on trouve plus en France
sur Internet qui arrive de l'étranger
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui un business
parallèle sur le médicament c'est
incroyable ça c'est c'est c'est le ils
vont en Italie la chercher du doliprane
ils ont la chance ils habitent près
d'Italie mais au-delà de ça ça serait
terrible on contrôle pas tout on
commence à se fournir en médicaments qui
sont frelatés
beaucoup moins cher mais qui va les
contrôler ces médicaments
peut se retrouver avec des médicaments
qu'on a jamais commandé sur internet je
vous le dis vraiment c'est une maladie
infectieuses avec des antibiotiques on
joue pas voilà parce que vous pourrez
pas contrôler ce qu'il y a dans la
gélules merci merci à vous de l'avoir
été avec nous soit de nous avoir alerté
tout de suite c'est les Chevaliers du
fiel sur C8